Apple just updated their iPhones and I
got myself the iPhone 10's max not just
because my name is max but because
mainly I wanted the larger screen size
compared to my iPhone 10 now I did watch
the announcement and they really focused
on the camera updates that they made but
honestly I was not expecting that much
because the iPhone 10 already looked
great for a smart phone and most
companies really tried to play up their
updates to get you to buy the newest one
after I got my hands on and after I went
out and start taking photos I was
honestly shocked by how good these
images look both with the portrait mode
and the smart HDR functionality so I
decided to put it against one of the
most popular cameras and the best deals
on the market right now the Sony a7 3
now for this comparison I want to do it
first starting off blind style I want
you guys to get a notepad a piece of
paper open up an app on your phone and
I'm gonna show you images side by side
one is Mark a1 is marked B write down
which one you like better or maybe write
down which one you think is the iPhone
if you want to do it that way and you
can pause it if you want a little bit
more time to take a look and then at the
end I'm gonna give you guys the results
which one is which and let me know your
honest opinions down in the comment
section below so I wanted to match this
up as best as I can so I'm using a 28
millimeter f2 that matches up very
closely with the 26 millimeter lens on
the back here and for the telephoto lens
this one I believe is a 56 millimeter
and here I have the sony 55 millimeter
so very close as far as focal length and
then I also matched up the blur with a
blur adjustment for the portrait shot so
I'm gonna have links to all of these
lenses and the camera and the video
description just in case you guys want
to check that out let's take a look at
that and then afterwards I will give you
my opinion on the images
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright guys so hopefully that was
interesting if you did not write down
your results of which one you thought
was the iPhone or which one you
preferred please pause the video go back
write it down it's much more fun that
way
and I'm gonna tell you the results in a
second here to give you enough time to
pause so the iPhone was the one marked
letter B so please let me know in the
comment section below how many of those
did you get right how much often did you
guess that which one was the iPhone or
if you did it the other way how often
did you prefer the iPhone photo and I do
want to let you know that I in no way
gave the upper hand to the iPhone I
literally took the phone out hit the
shutter button and that is all with the
a 73 often times I actually took three
four or five photos found the one with
the best exposure I did have dynamic
range optimization turned on and it was
interesting and in a couple of those
shots they actually turned on the HDR
mode and I maximized it to six evie it
took much longer with the a7 3 compared
to the iPhone and the smart HDR and here
is just so impressive if you guys have
heard of the term computational
photography you're not just trying to
improve the sensor or the lens here
you're trying to stack images together
do tone mapping do the HDR functionality
a lot of what Apple is doing with this
new iPhone and some other companies are
really pushing that to the limits as
well and I really would like to see that
more so in some of these you know
high-end camera so they take advantage
of that to take multiple photos and be
able to process them starting off with
this first image I was shocked by how
well the smart HDR worked this was
almost a High Noon the shadows are very
dark in real life the e73 is about kind
of what it looked like maybe brought up
the shadows a little bit more than real
life but the iPhone really made the
image look good it really retained all
the details there
of course the image isn't as sharp and I
think it's a little bit over sharpened
but it got all the highlights in the
shadows and it's a great looking image
likewise with the second image I think
the smart HDR is actually bringing up
the shadows a little bit too much I
think it needs a little bit more
contrast looks a bit flat but it's
shocking by how much detail it retains
in those shadows here's our first
portrait mode photo I do
prefer that a 7-3 has more contrast but
the iPhone did a great job to pick her
up and separate her from the background
they've been getting much much better at
that I don't see any weird artifacting
or edging and the blur @f 1.8 setting on
the iPhone looks really nice and
realistic too here's another portrait
shots at 2f 1.8 the separation isn't
perfect but it's pretty impressive for
how much different edges there are in
the fact that it's not a person the
background on this shot was really dark
and there was a lot of highlights here
the smart hgri did a great job on the
sony you really need to edit this
yourself even with the dynamic range
optimization mode kicked up but in
reality it was really dark in the
background there the iPhone just makes
it look like a completely different
scene and the book looks great on the
iPhone too this was the biggest shocker
it was dark inside my house it was super
bright outside
I set the a7 3 to HDR mode with 6 evie
the most HDR II could do and I shot like
4 or 5 photos and I chose the one that
looked the best in warth the iPhone I
literally hit the shutter button once it
did a great job pushing up those shadows
and retaining most of the highlights
outside the window and it is so
impressive with the color and when what
it did it's it's shocking honestly we'll
take a look at some raw photos
afterwards in this scenario the a7 3
definitely looks better an actual lens
could separate your subject just based
on what you're focusing where the iPhone
has to kind of blur all those edges and
ends up blurring a lot of leaves the
Smarty Shiar is crazy because that hot
spot on the right hand side was super
bright but we don't have enough contrast
just looks flat there's too much HDR
it's doing too good of a job in terms of
HDR you could add a little bit contrast
back in but I like the sony shot and
here's our first selfie I was really
impressed with the front facing camera
portrait mode the background is blurred
about as much as with f/2 on my Sony but
shooting at f/2 you see my face is in
focus and my son is out of focus where
the iPhone kind of picked up both of our
faces and kind of did a gradual blur so
anyways the sony shot looks better but
you can't really shoot at an f2 if you
want to keep both subjects in focus now
this is a low light mode at f 2.8 is
about a thousand iso on the a 73 the
noise is very
on the iPhone because of the stacking of
the images the edging on this hair and
his ear isn't perfect which obviously on
the a 7-3 it is perfect it's real but I
was impressed with the tone mapping if
you look at his face you have these the
highlights and the shadows are just a
really gradual looks really Pleasant
where the a7 3s image that's actually
what it looked like in real life so the
iPhone is making the shot and the scene
look better than it actually is and kind
of brightening up certain area so even
though it's not a sharp it's a great
looking image now we're getting even
darker with the wide-angle camera and of
course the sony looks sharper we have a
little bit more separation from the
background and as far as the scene the
sony is very realistic it was kind of
cooler and we had kind of darker on the
carpet and the rug where the iphone just
made it more pleasant looking as far as
white balance even though it's not as
realistic and it brought up those
shadows which gives you a nice looking
image but it's not what it looked like
in reality shooting the same shot but
with portrait mode the iphone just does
not have enough light the image starts
looking horrible it's very noisy with
artifacts it's not very sharp where we
have a nice pleasing looking image even
though it's quite dark here with the
full-frame sensor and lastly this is a
nighttime shot with a distant street
lamp we have the city in the background
I'm able to kick up the ISO there's
enough light coming in that I can get
this beautiful looking image on the
iPhone I was really surprised by how
close that blur the bokeh actually
matches it's not just making like
pokeballs and blurring it out it's
shaping the bokeh to what you would get
with this actual lens which is basically
the same style of lens from that focal
length equivalent the iPhone just was
not able to gather enough light because
it is a F 2.8 aperture and it's a much
smaller sensor for that portrait camera
than the wide-angle camera so it's
grainy but I was just so impressed with
that bokeh so if you're actually doing
nighttime photography obviously you want
to get a real camera I know that some of
you will say I should be shooting in RAW
with the a7 3 that's how you maximize
your image quality and yes that is
absolutely true
and for just family photos and personal
stuff it's not worth it yes if I'm
getting paid to shoot images
I'm absolutely shooting raw but just
like on the phone if I'm just going out
to shoot I'm shooting JPEG but I still
want to show you guys there
of shooting rah so here is the
comparison shooting JPEG with the best
HDR with a 7-3 versus the smart HDR and
the iPhone big difference and I think
the iPhone looks better here is RAW
images they use Lightroom to take a raw
image with the iPhone and comparing it
to an edited raw image with the a7 3 and
yes the a7 3 image looks great the image
is so noisy when I pushed up the shadows
on the iPhone and with how good
computational photography is you'd be
much better off just opening the camera
app
taking a photo with JPEG the results are
actually better overall so that is
impressive the computational photography
part of course you can get some better
images shooting raw but that took me at
least 2-3 minutes maximizing the image
from the a7 3 and it is impressive how
close the JPEG comes to the raw image
out of this iPhone that's you know a
thousand or $1,100 so let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
make sure you guys hit that subscribe
button if you guys want to see more
videos like this one we're gonna have
reviews we're gonna have a lot of tech
related videos on this channel and
please enable those notifications once
again I'm gonna have links to the lenses
and the camera that I used in the
description so make sure to go check
that out this has been max and I will
see you in the next video